die leute die man ruft werden wirklich
so jetzt wird's brenzlig ist auf die man
sich wirklich verlassen können muss wenn
die rechtsextreme chat betreiben
untereinander wenn vorgesetzte das
wissen nicht dagegen eintreten nicht
einschreiten dann von einem geschmäckle
zu sprechen wäre und das ist schon total
und vertrieben das ist für mich eine
situation als versagen
[Musik]
ich starte direkt mit der ersten frage
von 13 fragen mit der konflikt frage
versagen staatliche institutionen im
kampf gegen rechtsextremismus wenn ihr
sagt ja die versagen dann könnt ihr aufs
grüne feld gehen und wenn ihr sagt nee
das kann man so nicht sagen
dann könnt ihr aufs gelbe fällt gehen ok
dann wissen wir wo ihr steht der
rechtsextreme terroranschlag in hanau
auf eine synagoge in halle oder der mord
an walter lübke in kassel
all das passiert in weniger als einem
jahr und macht deutlich deutschland hat
ein problem mit rechtsextremismus
die nsu morde angriffe auf unterkünfte
für geflüchtete oder auch die
ausschreitung in chemnitz zeigen
außerdem er ist und war schon immer
allgegenwärtig viele sind der meinung
dass vor allem staatliche institutionen
also polizei bundeswehr und justiz im
kampf gegen rechten terror immer wieder
versagen andere sind wiederum der
meinung dass die ziemlich gut
aufgestellt sind bei 310 fragen sind
sich meine gäste erst mal uneinig umso
spannender wird es sein werden sie am
ende dann doch ein kompromiss finden wie
wir rechten terror in deutschland besser
bekämpfen können oder vielleicht sogar
eine lösung wir werden sehen wo würdet
ihr euch hinstellen seid ihr der meinung
dass die staatlichen institutionen
versagen im kampf gegen rechten terror
ja oder nein
grün oder gelb schreibt es mir gerne mal
in die kommentare dann gilt für euch ab
jetzt wenn ihr der anderen seite
zustimmen wollt dann könnt ihr einen
schritt einfach auf die zu gehen ins
nächste kassieren oder auch innerhalb
eurem kästchen und wenn ihr sauer seit
über etwas was jemand anders sagt dann
könnt ihr auch währenddessen einen
schritt zurückgehen und mein ziel ist
natürlich am ende so viele von euch im
kompromiss feld zu sehen für mich wäre
es gut gruben ich möchte mit dir beginn
du bist in einer traditionell jüdischen
familie in frankfurt am main geboren und
aufgewachsen
du setzt sich ein für eine jüdische
gemeinde gegen antisemitismus gegen
diskriminierung kannst du den moment
beschreiben also von dem anschlag in
halle auf eine synagoge gehört hast das
kann ich tatsächlich sehr sehr gut und
zwar war ich da gerade im gottesdienst
in der synagoge und hatte mein handy so
wie es wirklich ist aus und es war als
ich so eine unruhe
generell in der ganzen synagoge
ausgebreitet aber niemand wusste genau
was passiert ist und dann bin ich nach
hause gegangen der zwar in der zeit
zwischen den beiden gebeten und als ich
abends dann wieder in richtung snow
gegangen sind war viel mehr polizei vor
ort
bewaffnete beamtinnen und hab da wusste
ich irgendwas passiert und es war für
mich ein schock aber es war keine
überraschung weil dieser anschlag in
einer kontinuität rechten terrors in
deutschland steht staatliche
institutionen versagen im kampf gegen
rechtsextremismus weil die gefahr seit
jahren unterschätzt wird und
gleichermaßen auch die gesellschaft im
kampf in diesem kampf versagt weil die
bedrohung einfach nicht ernst genommen
wird und sagt also es war für ihn keine
überraschung würde theben dazu stimmen
geht die erst mal einen schritt auf oben
zu
so halt darum war das ein kleiner
schritt weil die grundsatzfrage
natürlich dies wäre hätte es denn
voraussehen können um gerade in dem
konkreten fall na klar es gab eine
abstrakte gefährdung schon seit vielen
jahren nicht nur die jüdischen gemeinden
sondern auch die sicherheitsbehörden
haben davor gewarnt aber diesen
konkreten überfall auf die
synagogengemeinde in halle den konnte
nun wirklich niemand voraussehen dann ja
ich kann das eigentlich auch nur
bekräftigen letztendlich können wir nur
sozusagen mit den instrumenten arbeiten
die uns gegeben sind und dazu gehört es
eben nicht dass wir alles vorhersehen
können sondern gerade bei der polizei
ist natürlich auch viele reaktionen am
ende dabei
es gibt sicherlich fehler die passiert
sind und auch fehler die passieren und
defizite die wir abstellen müssen in den
sicherheitsbehörden aber versagen ist
absolut und das kann man nicht behaupten
da wir auch sehr erfolgreich
rechtsextremisten sowohl beim
verfassungsschutz beobachten als auch
polizeilich strafrechtlich verfolgen
was macht das mit der wende das wärs es
macht ein bisschen mulmiges gefühl weil
ich glaube auf den konkreten anschlag
vielleicht auch viele andere anschläge
walter lübke beispielsweise glaube ich
schon dass man dann mit konkreten
maßnahmen sachen verhindern hätte können
das gleiche gilt für hanau ich glaube da
läuft einiges schief namie kannst du
dich dann noch an den terroranschlag in
hanna erinnern an dem moment wo du davon
erfahren hast und kannst du dich auch
noch an die reaktion der migrantischen
community erinnern also es war es war
eine katastrophe vereinen also ich bin
mit einem freund unterwegs gewesen und
ich weiß noch wie ich zu ihm gesagt habe
dass an dir vorbei gelaufen weil mein
freund blond war aber mich hat er
wahrscheinlich getroffen das war so eine
unmittelbarkeit die die aber krass ist
und war das für dich so ähnlich wie
haben gerade gesagt hat keine
überraschungen oder nicht glaubt rechts
terroristische anschläge in deutschland
überraschen mich um ehrlich zu sein
nicht also spätestens seit dem nsu seit
rostock lichtenhagen seit solingen also
es gibt so viele
attentate die sich immer wieder
summieren und 1 folgt auf den nächsten
also man fragt sich im grunde genommen
glaube ich und auch in der migrantischen
community nur wann passiert dass das
nächste mal
ich würde nicht sagen dass der deutsche
staat auf dem rechten auge komplett
blind ist aber ich glaube es gibt
erhebliche defizite die es aufzuarbeiten
gilt beispielsweise fallen immer wieder
rechtsextreme gruppen von polizisten
auch von spezialeinheiten auf ich denke
wir müssen ein bisschen vielleicht
vorsichtig sein und das thema ab
schichten ich glaube wir sind uns einig
schon in der alten bundesrepublik hat
der rechtsterrorismus eine blutspur
hinterlassen
bei vielen gelegenheiten und da fallen
mir auch einige jüdische opfer ein
du hast eben von rostock lichtenhagen
gesprochen auch das waren alles dinge
die uns eigentlich hätten nicht nur
schmerzen müssen sondern wir uns hätten
klar machen müssen
hier sind gravierende fehler passiert in
den behörden aber die grundsatzfrage ist
die wie wird jemand zu einem extremisten
in einer gesellschaft egal welches
politische phänomen
und da sage ich niemand wird als
antisemit oder als extremist geboren
sondern eine gesellschaft macht menschen
erst dazu und da sage ich ganz offen
wenn wir argumentativ sagen die behörden
haben versagt oder teile der behörden
haben versagt dann müssen wir mindestens
genauso deutlich sagen auch diese
gesellschaft hat versagt ich mache gerne
eine diskussion mit denjenigen auf die
der ansicht sind dass staatliche
institutionen versagt haben um auch
deutlich zu machen dass sich einerseits
natürlich fehler erkennen furchtbare
fehler die zu ganz furchtbaren
konsequenzen geführt haben nsu es nur
ein stichwort aber auch walter lübke
aber auf der anderen seite möchte ich
schon mit ihnen diskutieren um zu
beleuchten aus den unterschiedlichen
blickwinkeln was zu tun ist um überhaupt
rechts extremismus und terrorismus zu
begegnen aktie ich würde dir gerne eine
frage stellen und zwar bist du mit 13
jahren in die rechte szene gekommen
kannst du das mal erklären wie landet
man in der rechten szene wie kommt man
da rein vor allem auch so jung also
letztlich ist es immer wenn ich junge
menschen ich war 13 jahre alt wie gesagt
in die szene kommen
aus überzeugung sondern meistens
aufgrund von bauchgefühl
ja und ich hatte damals in der schule
ein projekt für das sich die nicht im
bundestag vertretenden parteien die
wahlprogramme organisieren sollte um
eine collage mitzumachen
hab das mit großem eifer getan und die
lehrerin hat mir dafür ein 1 1 gegeben
aber haben dann die rechten parteien
republikaner npd und dvu zur damaligen
zeit darunter genommen mit dem vermerk
er den geben wir keine plattform und das
hat interesse bei mir geweckt ich hab
dann die parteien angeschrieben die npd
hat sich bei mir zurückgemeldet und so
habe ich dann angefangen kritische
fragen unterricht zu stellen und darauf
wurde eben dann nicht mit mir diskutiert
sondern eben dann du bist jetzt stell du
hältst die klappe das wird hier nicht
verbreitet eine ungerechte behandlung so
habe ich das damals empfunden
und da hat die szene dann angesetzt die
rechtsextreme szene und sagte schau
stellst nur fragen die wird über den
mund gefahren mit dir wirklich
diskutiert das ist doch keine echte
demokratie in die wir leben und schon
war ich in dieser szene drin und ja
leider waren 15 jahre lang geblieben das
thema liegt mir deswegen am herzen weil
ich selber ja eine schuld auf mich
geladen habe ich bin jahrelang
organisator netzwerker und erlebnisse in
dieser szene
ich habe junge menschen dazu gebracht in
dieser szene sich zu betätigen und habe
deren geist vergiftet mit hassparolen
ich distanziere mich heute ganz klar von
rechtsextremismus wie von jedem
extremistischem gedankengut ich
verurteile den rassismus ich verurteile
die menschenfeindlichkeit
ich verurteile das ausschließlichkeit
denken und deswegen ist es nur recht und
billig dass ich heute meinen teil dazu
beitragen und sage es tut mir leid was
ich gemacht habe macht bitte nicht diese
empfehle habe ich sie gemacht haben
du stehst aber trotzdem auf der
gegenseite das heißt du bist der meinung
dass die staatlichen institutionen beim
kampf gegen rechtsextremismus nicht
versagt haben warum aus eigener
erfahrung kann ich sagen ich habe sehr
viele kundgebungen demonstrationen
angemeldet und veranstaltet und hatte da
natürlich auch einen intensiven kontakt
mit behörden sei es polizeipräsidien sei
es versammlungsbehörden und ich habe es
wirklich nie erlebt dass da eine wenn
auch unterschwellige sympathie geäußert
worden wäre im gegenteil da ist immer
ganz klar gemacht worden auch okay ihr
dürft ihr recht in anspruch nehmen aber
wir machen es euch nicht einfach ja und
ich habe auch die strafverfolgung selber
erlebt
wo ich gesehen habe dass eben dann da
schon mit argusaugen darüber gewacht
wurde was leute daneben und straftaten
begehen die sind in der szene
allgegenwärtig na ja und so kann ich
nicht sagen dass der staat da versagt
hat natürlich gibt es immer versäumnisse
ja gerade die angesprochene themen haben
ja gezeigt dass da die behörden auch
nicht immer in der wünschenswerten
klarheit eben stellung bezogen haben
nämlich ist denn deiner meinung nach die
polizei auf dem rechten auge blind
ich will nicht unbedingt unbedingt sagen
dass die polizei auf dem rechten auge
blind ist aber es gibt erhebliche
defizite die es auf jeden fall
aufzuarbeiten gilt abgesehen davon ist
auch die polizei immer wieder durchsetzt
von menschen mit rechten einstellungen
oder rechtsextremen einstellungen immer
wieder von chat gruppen auf vor kurzem
wurde das frankfurter sek aufgelöst die
sicherheitsbehörden oder die menschen
die in diesen sicherheitsbehörden
arbeiten sind nicht gefeit davor
rechtsextreme einstellungen an den tag
zu legen also die leute die man ruft
wenn wirklich also wenn es brenzlig ist
auf die man sich wirklich verlassen
können muss wenn die rechtsextremen zu
betreiben untereinander wenn vorgesetzte
das wissen und nicht eintreten oder
nicht ich denke nicht dagegen eintreten
wie ich einschreiten dann also ich finde
es hat also von einem geschmäckle zu
sprechen wäre und das ist schon total
unter drehen das ist für mich ein
institutionelles versagen bevor der
polizist selber vielleicht ein paar
worte dazu sagen ich meine man muss so
viel sei noch sieht man ja jetzt fast
wöchentlich werden die nächsten skandale
über chat gruppen und andere sachen
herauskommen das viel zu lange wir
glaube ich ein ausbildungs ein
weiterbildungs und ein führungsproblem
in der polizei hatten also das kann ich
auch bestätigen
von otto siebenbürger polizei aus dem
boden der demokratie aber die dabei sind
verderben nicht nur das ganze sondern
was sagen denn die anderen die
eigentlich nicht so gesehen werden
wollen und da wird vielleicht unsere
schuldigkeit gruppen nie durch
irgendwelche anderen polizistinnen
aufgeflogen sind sondern immer durch
andere sachen so wie beispielsweise im
kinderpornografie oder irgendwas anderes
sie sind nie aufgekommen weil
irgendjemand gesagt hat so ey das ist
nicht in ordnung und ich gehe damit
irgendwann die öffentlichkeit im
gegenteil du hast recht in der mehrzahl
der fälle sich von außen aufgedeckt
worden aber ich musste ehrenhalber schon
sagen ich kenne einige polizisten
polizisten die danach wirklich es ihm
nach schlimmen und schwer zu getan weil
sie in der truppe dann ausgesondert
wurden die den mut hatten dinge auch
tageslicht zu finden aber ich gebe euch
recht die mehrzahl ist von außen
bekommen hat deswegen braucht es doch
strukturen wo sich zb beamte die sich
auf dem boden der freiheitlichen
grundordnung bewegen hinwenden können
die nicht polizeiintern sozusagen
arbeiten und die extern ausgelagert
eigene ermittlungskompetenzen haben
stattdessen muss man ein bisschen
polizisten gegen polizisten ermitteln
und derjenige der die sozusagen als
nestbeschmutzer gilt der etwas sagt er
sich traut der wird ausgesondert der
wird ausgegrenzt und wird seines lebens
nicht mehr froh das ist was was du
unterstützen würden oder wasser stehen
könnte ich will nur sagen man muss mit
den ressourcen die wir haben auch
arbeiten und dass die die
rahmenbedingungen haben die
sicherheitsbehörden nicht alleine in der
hand so das ist erst mal festzuhalten
und wenn ich möchte dass
rechtsextremismus vernünftig bekämpft
wird muss ich die sicherheitsbehörden
ausstatten politische aufgabe und das
was ihr gesagt hab da bin ich sogar
sofort dabei wir müssen neben dem was
der verfassungsschutz ist schon macht zu
gucken was haben wir einen extremisten
in den behörden müssen wir natürlich
auch wissenschaftlich reingucken ja auch
sozusagen in einem level was jetzt nicht
strafrechtlich relevant ist sondern auch
vorher schon ja wenn jemand
rassistischen spruch macht ist ja nicht
automatisch ein rechtsextremist aber er
gehört trotzdem betrachtet deswegen wäre
eine studie des innenministeriums auch
nicht gewesen dazu stattdessen bekommen
wir eine studie über den polizeialltag
genauso wichtig oder zumindest auch
wichtig aber das ist nicht die frage
die ist leider nicht weitgehend genug
aber ich denke auch wir müssen schauen
dass wir da insgesamt uns breiter
aufstellen dass wir wissen schafft
dauerhaft zu lassen und nicht sozial
sagt dazu wir sind aber schon ganz schön
weit nach vorne und und auch das letzter
punkt die stimme auch zu mit einer
unabhängigen untersuchung und mit einem
polizei beauftragten der auch
tatsächlich diesen namen verdient hat
und das ist bei weitem noch nicht so
dass wir das überall haben denn die
anonymität von kolleginnen und kollegen
die sich dorthin wenden ist nicht
überall sicher ja und das ist ein
problem
also da sind wir glaube ich ziemlich
dicht florian da sicher intensiv mit
rechtsextremismus in deutschland
auseinandergesetzt und auch ein buch
darüber geschrieben würdest du sagen das
recht der terror 20 21 auch vielleicht
eine ganz andere dimension noch
angenommen
eine neue dimension denn es gibt er
weiterhin diesen analogen
rechtsextremismus das haben wir gesehen
mit dem fall nsu und es gab ja auch
jemanden der früher in der rechten szene
war nämlich der mörder von walter lübcke
den ich auch zu diesen analogen
rechtsextremismus zähle aber es gibt
eben auch zusätzlich diese dimension der
virtuellen radikalisierung wo man dann
eben letzten endes sich dann nicht mehr
auf die wörtliche kameradschaft bezieht
sondern eben auf einen breivik und
übrigens der treter von halle hat er
auch ein vorbild nämlich zum einen
breivik und den täter von christchurch
ursprünglich hatte sogar überlegt nach
christchurch eine moschee anzugreifen
also diese täte inspirieren sich
gegenseitig in diesen virtuellen räumen
ich habe mich sehr intensiv mit dem
thema einzelne wölfe der neue
terrorismus rechte einzeltäter
beschäftigt mit dem phänomen des sozial
isolierten aber virtuell vernetzten
mannes man mag so da mal kurz den
unterschied erklären einfach damit alle
auch die zuschauerinnen verstehen können
was ist dann der unterschied zwischen
einem einzeltäter einzel täterin und
einem einsamen wolfes dann muss ich
sagen ich weiß das jetzt ändern das ist
auch gut und schön in dem fall passt es
nicht es gibt keine einsame wölfe sind
nämlich alles männer und frauen
hassspiel die eine sehr sehr wichtige
rolle in diesem radikalisierungsprozess
sie sagen teilweise dass sie niemals in
ihrem leben eine beziehung hatten der
täter von hanau schreibt in seinem
manifest das einmal in seinem leben ein
date hatte also das ist ein männer
phänomen und der unterschied ist eben
dass diese täter eben sehr stark auf
spiele plattformen aktiv sind und eben
letzten endes sich dann auch selber
radikalisieren der täter von hana hat
sich sehr stark über youtube
radikalisiert und eben der täter von
münchen oder der täter von halle die
waren eben sehr stark auf steam aktiv
und in diesen einschlägigen chats und
eben dann auch mit diesen symbolen wie
eben techno barbaren und eben auch der
starke antisemitismus der in diesen
foren eine wichtige rolle spielt wie
eben auch andere behörden
sicherheitsbehörden in den usa schon
auch seit einiger zeit feststellen dass
hier eben verschlüsselt kommuniziert
wird deswegen ist es natürlich wichtig
auf der einen seite dass wir über
whatsapp gruppen bei der polizei
sprechen aber das ist eben ein anderes
phänomen
diesen katalog den du gerade sehr
schönen aufgezählt hass hat sich bei
youtube radikalisiert hatten mehr wie
fest- vorher veröffentlicht hat
beziehungsprobleme gehabt wir haben es
bis jetzt nur mit männern zu tun
das alles heißt aber nicht dass wenn wir
diese punkte in unser raster reinsetzen
wir todsicher dem nächsten erwischen wir
können auch heute gar nicht vorstellen
ob es nicht vielleicht in zukunft auch
eine lohn zum wohnen ist wir erleben zum
beispiel gerade im bereich des links
aber auch des rechtsextremismus hat
gerade letzte woche im vortrag darüber
halten die rolle der frauen in den
extremismus bereich sammeln gehst ja sie
ist eine freundin lena muss noch das
frauen selber nicht nur als briefträger
sondern als an schlägerinnen als
diejenigen täterinnen auftreten deswegen
mein petitum an der stelle ist nur ja
wir lernen alle und behörden sollten
besonders schnell lernen und wir haben
in vielen bereichen leider noch nicht
gelernt wirklich gestehe ich ein
aber wir sollen bitte nicht so tun als
wenn es schon die festen lösungen und
antworten auf all die fragen gibt die in
den schubladen sind wird dazu was gern
wichtiges anmerken ich selber als
rechtsextremer agitator weiß ja was für
eine sprache in der szene gepflegt wird
und verbale totschläger ist jeder
rechtsextremist das heißt von den 34.000
bekannten rechtsextremisten wird jeder
schon mal geschrieben haben klubs am
nächsten baum auf wir müssen mehr machen
wahlen bringen niklas zur waffe greifen
ist es natürlich dann sehr schwierig bei
diesem wust von verbalradikalismus zu
filtern
wer schreitet jetzt zur tat und wer
produziert sich jetzt einfach nur damit
der applaus von seinen kameraden bekommt
ich denke das kann auch keine behörde
der welt tatsächlich dann übersehen
gerade wenn das feld noch dann viel
weiter ausgeweitet wird auf soziale
plattform wo in der anonymität in jeder
hinsicht leute sehr schnell viel
radikaler und viel extremer werden da
auch genau aus zu differenzieren
der ist jetzt eine gefahr da müssen wir
gucken dass er kein anschlag begeht oder
ja gut das ist jetzt ein 15-jähriger
darum träumt und sich damit wichtig
machen will
ich denke mal wenn wir keinen
polizeistaat haben wollen muss man da
tatsächlich immer auch so blöd das
klingt learning by doing machen und
dinge auszuforschen dann auch genauer
nach göttern zu erkennen da sind
schritte gewesen die haben wir vor nicht
auf dem blickfeld gehabt und jetzt
erkennen wir erst einmal okay da müssen
wir künftig genau hinsehen
oder dann stelle ich mir die frage wie
fast 400 rechtsextreme einfach
untertauchen können und da ist mein
lieblingsbeispiel attila hildmann der
wahrscheinlich der prominenteste
rechtsextremer ist der alles mögliche
von morddrohungen beleidigung
volksverhetzung und so weiter und so
fort in aller öffentlichkeit über ein
jahr lang der ganzen welt im endeffekt
preisgegeben hat wie es dann sein kann
dass er in die türkei ausreisen kann wie
kann jemand wie athen erhält man dann ja
das ist tatsächlich ein bisschen
spekulation weil wir ja die wege nicht
kennen wie er darüber geht letztendlich
wie viele andere kriminelle auch
schaffen es eben immer mal wieder welche
auch sozusagen durch zu schlüpfen was
muss denn passieren damit der eben
niemand mehr durch schlüpfen kann oder
zumindest so wenige wie möglich es wird
kein niemand irgendwann geben wir müssen
uns einfach mit der realität anfreunden
wir werden keine absolute sicherheit
hinbekommen dass wir besser werden
können und nach möglichkeit eben diese
fehler die jetzt passiert sind auch
wirklich aufzuarbeiten was noch lange
nicht begonnen hat da bin ich ganz bei
euch aber wir sollten nicht so tun als
wenn alles normal wäre ich könnte jetzt
was ich leider nicht darf zwei beispiele
bringen wo wir gerade in den letzten
vier wochen drei behörden zwei
14-jähriger gefunden haben die zu hause
in ihrer eigenen elterlichen wohnung
waffen und sprengstoff gehortet haben wo
wir es verhindern konnten darüber
schreibt niemand ihr habt ja gerade
schon fleißig zumindest immer wieder hat
es versucht kompromissvorschläge
auszutauschen oder ideen möglichkeiten
was man machen könnte
im rechten terror und deutschland
vielleicht besser zu bekämpfen und das
ist jetzt genau mein stichwort denn ich
möchte die kompromiss runde eröffnen in
der ich euch ein kompromissvorschlag mit
teil werde und mal gucken ob ihr auf
mich zum geht einen schritt das personal
in staatlichen behörden ist noch nicht
gut genug ausgebildet um rechten terror
effizient zu bekämpfen können wir uns
deshalb darauf einigen dass speziell im
kampf gegen den rechten terror
zugeschnittene ausbildungsprogramme bei
der polizei etabliert werden müssen wenn
er sagt ja dann könnt ihr jetzt ein
schritt auf mich zugehen
du bist kein schritt auf mich zugegangen
warum weil ich glaube dass es mehr als
ausbildung innerhalb der polizei und
sicherheitsbehörden braucht das kann ein
schritt sein aber ich glaube es braucht
dort nochmal viel systemische hre
wandlung als nur explosive ausbildung
stefan ach du hast dich nicht bewegen
hat schon gut zusammengefasst was auch
ich oder wo auch meine ja ich bin für
ausbildung sehr zu haben aber nicht nur
in den blumenstrauß nur ein blümchen
soll
ok dann könnt ihr jetzt gern nach den
weiteren blümchen suchen und die köpfe
zusammenstecken und euch einen neuen
vielleicht auch ein kompromissvorschlag
überlegen die zivilgesellschaft auf der
einen seite ja dass mindestens kann sagt
sina der sender genau nach dem
liedhaften und auch andere programme
geschaffen werden müssen die leute
wieder zurückgewichen
es ist auf jeden fall nicht einfach bei
dem thema jetzt kompromissvorschläge zu
finden ich weiß nicht ob ihr zuhause
gerade vielleicht noch ideen in eurem
kopf hab ich bin gespannt welche lösung
hier gleich von beiden seiten
präsentiert werden
also ich bin sie den verfassungsschutz
als institution super kritisch ich
brauche das alles verspricht ausgehalten
kann ich gerne ich möchte euch jetzt die
grüne seite fragen zu welchen
kompromissvorschlag seite gekommen
also unser kompromiss wäre dass wir eine
differenzierte debatte anbieten würden
dass wir uns die einzelnen
sicherheitsbehörden individuelle
anschauen und nicht alles alle
sicherheitsbehörden in einen topf werfen
sondern uns anschauen was braucht es für
veränderungen beispielsweise beim
verfassungsschutz
da gibt es ja verschiedene politische
ideen zum beispiel auch von abschaffung
sehr radikal bis reform die aber alle
irgendwie nicht klappen weil es eine
immunisierung gibt dass man diese
behörden überhaupt nicht anfassen darf
gleichzeitig müssen wir schauen was kann
man bei der polizei verändern was kann
man beim bka verändern und gleichzeitig
auch die politik freut zum beispiel mit
parlamentarischer kontrolle stärker in
die pflicht nehmen wenn es diese
möglichkeit gibt weil oftmals wird das
auch von seiten der behörden torpediert
und ganz wichtig auch die
zivilgesellschaft stärker in den in die
verantwortung ziehen weil letztendlich
in unserer gesellschaft wie als
zivilgesellschaft dafür sorge tragen
dass so etwas nicht passieren kann dass
das rechtsextremer terror im keim
erstickt wird gewisser weise
und ich glaube da braucht es ein
zusammenspiel von politik gesellschaft
aber auch von sicherheitsbehörden die
ich aktuell durch den aktuell nicht so
sehen und die zu einem massiven
vertrauensverlust in sehr vielen
bereichen der gesellschaft führen kann
das war der kompromiss vorschlag der
grünen seite könnt ihr euch jetzt gerne
dazu positionieren einen schritt auf die
grüne seite zu gehen
lange ist der einzige der ein schritt
geht warum
ja weil ich glaube dass ganz viele
wichtige punkte genannt sind zum einen
eben auch in der debatte zu
differenzieren und zum anderen eben auch
sozusagen ein strauß von möglichkeiten
wie wir das
die schwierigkeiten die wir im moment
mindestens subjektiv aber auch viele auf
objektive fehler die wir im moment haben
konkret angehen können stefan warum hast
du keine chance auf der anderen seite
dazu gehört eine ganze menge oder die
gruppe besser gesagt hat eine ganze
menge habe ich wichtige punkte
angesprochen wo wir gar nicht so weit
entfernt sind von dem glaube ich was wir
auch vorschlagen werden aber was mir
immer noch so ein bisschen bitter
aufstößt ist das immer noch so
mitschwingt mehr kontrolle einzeln auf
den topf setzen
ich glaube dass das nicht zielführend
ist ich gebe nur ein beispiel wir haben
während des nsu zum beispiel im
verfassungsschutz genauso eine
parlamentarische kontrolle gehabt ein
innenministerium was eine fachaufsicht
gehabt hat und ich kann nur sagen wenn
die alle nicht mitbekommen haben was da
abgeht dann waren entweder die
verfassungsschützer sehr klandestin
unterwegs oder die haben alle gepennt
also mit anderen worten vielleicht war
es nämlich dass beide mischungen aus
beiden ja wir sind beim konsum ist gerne
aber fakt ist an dieser stelle ich
glaube noch mehr kontrolle als wir jetzt
schon haben wird das problem nicht lösen
aber ich denke wir haben einige aspekte
aber was bringt eine kontrolle wenn zum
beispiel von seiten der behörden
gemauert wird wenn wir können ja gar
nicht mal wo ich werde ich werde
regelmäßig einmal im monat aus dem topf
gesetzt waren aussagen von zeugen von
vornherein unter druck gesetzt werden
usw
das überhaupt nicht in
untersuchungsausschüssen das ans licht
kommen kann
das ist richtig da gebe ich dir recht da
muss man dann noch ein gesetz schreibt
darin zu gehen
da muss man dann aber da muss man dann
aber wirklich auch mal schauen was
können diese untersuchungsausschüsse was
dürfen sie und ich bin jetzt mal ganz
böse welche fachliche kompetenz haben
diejenigen die in den ausschüssen sitzen
und alles hinterfragen sollen aber vor
mir zu euren kompromissvorschlag kommen
axel jetzt hast du dich doch einen
kleinen schritt bewegt hätte ich dich
gerne noch mal gefragt warum du dich
nicht direkt bewegt hast also ich kann
auch bei vielen dingen zustimmen nur ich
finde die erwartungshaltung zu hoch
gegriffen wir werden rechtsextremen
terror genauso wenig im keime generell
ersticken können wie islamistischen
terror oder linksextrem terror ich bin
auch kein freund davon immer das so auf
die behörden dann ab zur welt und zu
sagen wir müssen jetzt die polizei das
lka und dem verfassungsschutz auf den
kopf stellen die gerichte gehören
genauso dazu ich habe das damals selber
oft erlebt dass eben viele dinge so die
polizei in ihrem denkzettel verpassen
wollte eben dann die gerichte angerufen
und gesagt haben von wegen
ist gegessen junge du kannst marschieren
du kannst machen was du willst ja und da
muss viel breiter angesetzt werden weil
rechtsextremismus oder andere
extremisten sind vor allem deswegen
attraktiv weil sie jugendlichen eine
erlebniswelt bieten und der beste
verfassungsschutz der welt ja und die
demokratischste polizeieinheit der welt
kann eben da nicht einschreiten wo eben
gesellschaftliche probleme dann am bach
sind und deswegen halte ich es für kurz
gegriffen und auch die erwartungshaltung
einfach zu hoch ihr könnt jetzt auch
gerne euren kompromissvorschlag
präsentieren
ja also wir haben uns ausgetauscht dass
wir eigentlich einen bunten strauß an
unternehmungen maßnahmen wie auch immer
man es nennen möchte brauchen die
einerseits zivilgesellschaftlich sind
also breites bewusstsein für die
problematik jugendämter müssen gestärkt
werden die ganze kommunale ebene muss
gestärkt werden um einfach sozusagen
diese entwicklung früher abzugreifen
das ist das eine und daneben also zu
sagen wir haben hier auch heute wieder
vertreter von zwei sicherheitsbehörden
es gibt aber noch viel viel viel mehr
und insbesondere bei der polizei auch
die justizbehörden die die
ermittlungsverfahren auch leitern von
denen wir abhängig sind wo wir als
polizei
manchmal auch einfach auf verlorenem
posten sind weil die justiz uns nicht
dem folgt was wir vorschlagen
das war der kompromissvorschlag der
geben seit ihr könnt euch jetzt wiederum
gerne gerne dazu positionieren
ich bin also ein bisschen ganz wie
gespalten bei dem was gesagt worden ist
zum einen weil ich ein problem sehe bei
diesem ganzen weil wenn über
zivilgesellschaftliches engagement reden
dann ist es sehr sehr häufig dass wenn
man beispielsweise eine
gegendemonstration gegen einen
neonazi-aufmarsch macht man von polizei
als störenfriede gesehen wird und man
wird eigentlich als das als die ursache
des problems gesehen nicht dass dort
irgendwelche neonazis marschieren
vielleicht kann ich ihn dazu bewegen und
wir gehen beide noch einen schritt nach
vorn und landen dann doch du musst aber
ein riesenschritt machen ich glaube was
ganz wichtig ist dass wir solche runden
wie wir sie jetzt hier gehabt haben mit
moderation die ausgezeichnet war aber
vielleicht auch ohne brauchen damit wir
gegenseitig aus den schützengräben
rauskommen die behörden sehen nicht
immer nur die zivilgesellschaft als den
feind auf der anderen seite und
vielleicht ein stück weit auch die
zivilgesellschaft die anfängt ein stück
weit vielleicht sich in
position hineinzuversetzen warum stellen
sich behörden so an wie sie sich
vielleicht manchmal anstellen was für
menschen aus zusagen nicht behörden
oftmals nicht nachvollziehbar ist dass
diejenigen die es jetzt wirklich
betrifft dann die justiz und jugendämter
und andere noch mit eingeschlossen dass
man sich wirklich mal zusammen setzt und
auch einfach mal zuhört was die
einzelnen zu erzählen haben was sie
umtreibt was sie bewegt um daraus ein
stück weit auch zu entwickeln hey hoppla
vielleicht sind wir gar nicht so weit
auseinander und der schritt aufeinander
zu ist viel einfacher möglich als uns
das vielleicht im moment alle vorstellen
aber was mich so ein bisschen stört an
diesem ganzen an dieser ganzen
gesellschaft sozusagen debatte über
gesamtgesellschaftliche verantwortung
ist auf der einen seite haben wir
behörden mit einem gewaltmonopol mit
ermittlungskompetenzen mit im
zweifelsfall waffen die sie bei der
durchsetzung der interessen des staates
einsetzen dürfen auf der anderen seite
haben wir die gesellschaft die breit
aufgestellt ist es gibt menschen die er
von der rechten terror betroffen sind
als andere
und da diese verantwortung sozusagen
gleichmäßig aufteilen zu wollen das
finde ich verkehrt also ich möchte dass
wir sozusagen aus dieser runde heraus
gehen und sagen die die latte die wir an
die behörden stellen ist weitaus höher
als die die werden rest der gesellschaft
stellen
ich gehe einen schritt vor ich bin mit
ihr völlig einer meinung wir haben halt
behörden eine besondere verantwortung
und die sind ist dieses
diskussionsangebot was ich jetzt machen
wollte heißt auf gar keinen fall dass
ich das ausgleichen und so nach dem
motto ihr seid genauso dafür zuständig
wie wir da drüben sag ich mal in der
zivilgesellschaft das ist was anderes
und trotzdem sage ich am ende wenn wir
nicht miteinander kommunizieren und
funktionieren werden wir dieses problem
nicht gelöst kriegen aber wir haben eine
besondere verantwortung als behörden
ich möchte dass die sicherheitsbehörden
auf allen ebenen besser werden ich
möchte dass unsere gesellschaft
eines tages so frei wie möglich von
rechtsextremen tendenzen ist ich möchte
dass es unabhängige stellen gibt an die
ich mich als jemand der zum beispiel von
machtmissbrauch durch polizistinnen und
polizisten betroffen ist wenden kann und
ich möchte dass diesen dieser dieser
beschwerde dann auch konsequent und
ergebnisorientiert und offen
nachgegangen wird und das ist derzeit
noch nicht der fall
ich würde mir auch wünschen dass wir das
tatsächlich auch in unseren alltag
regelmäßig einbauen können dass wir mit
communitys ins gespräch kommen die
vielleicht kritisch auf die
sicherheitsbehörden blicken und daneben
auch ein gegenseitiges verständnis
vielleicht herstellen können ich stehe
jederzeit bereit sehr gut ich bedanke
mich auf jeden fall sehr bei euch viel
die diskussion
danke für die moderation die diskussion
hat wie so oft schon gezeigt dass
natürlich die zeit die wir hier bei 310
fragen haben nicht reicht um so ein
problem einfach zu lösen wir können ein
paar kompromiss vorschläge machen die
vielleicht fruchten auch bei euch im
kopf und dann müssen wir die diskussion
einfach weiter führen welche argumente
haben euch denn überzeugt schreibt uns
in den kommentaren und falls euch die
diskussion angeregt hat dann lasst auch
sehr gerne ein abo dafür diesen kanal
hier oben findet ihr ein weiteres video
von 13 fragen und hier unten ein
weiteres video zum thema